hey so today we'll be loading models in
3ds
this is a major step when you're doing
3d stuff since it allows you to start
using
higher quality assets from the web
meaning you can go and download some
really cool looking pre-made stuff and
import it directly into your project
or you can build your own assuming you
have some art skills and
load it up in your project what we'll
cover today is loading and displaying a
model
in 3.js i'll show you some great sites
to get free resources and of course
we'll cover using blender to model
something export it and then loading the
model in 3.js
we'll also cover how to load and display
an animated model
alright sound good let's do it first
things first let's cruise on over to the
3.js site and see what formats they
support
they have this handy list here they
support a whole mess of formats but like
they call out here
they're not equally good and you should
probably stick to the recommended unless
you have a good reason otherwise
the recommended format being gltf as
mentioned right here
so let's look at some code i've got this
empty project that i've already started
you can see that i brought in all the
setup code from the last project
and i already have a test model called
rocket.gltf
first step is we need to import the
specific loader we need for the format
which is what this line here does then
we need to instantiate an
instance of a loader which is what we're
doing right here and then call
load with the path to the model and a
few callbacks
you need to specifically supply on load
and
optionally supply on progress and on air
this works fine as long as you minimally
supply
on load the other two are like i said
completely optional
when this runs we can drop a breakpoint
in the onload handler and see that the
parameter passed in has a scene member
which we can directly add to the scene
by calling scene.add
object dot scene for other formats this
is going to be slightly different each
time so you need to do something similar
meaning you might have to figure out
what exactly you need to add
anyway after we insert it into the scene
we can see it in the browser
there we've loaded a static model let's
walk through the process of getting one
from either website or blender
i'll fire up blender here and we'll
quickly model something maybe just mash
some cube scene shapes together i don't
know
it doesn't really matter since this is
just showing the process also i have no
art skills whatsoever
once we do that you just need to go to
the export menu here
most of the defaults here will do just
fine just select the name and you're set
and of course we can change the code to
load the new one and it works like
expected we get
whatever the hell this is i said that
we'd also cover
where to get some good free stuff one
site i like is sketch fab
you need to make an account but after
that you can go and search for whatever
you like
filter by downloadable here just to
clear up the list a bit
now some of these are paid you look at
that little dollar sign
but there's a lot of good free stuff
here just click on a model and you can
see how high resolution it is and hit
download if you want as well
there's also mixamo which is a site run
by adobe
and this is all totally free as well you
can check out there's a ton of content
here and you can also download the model
and animation separately lastly i've
used poly.google.com a few times to grab
some low poly models
you can check it out and see if there's
anything you like and of course download
in a few different formats
now let's go grab one of those fancy
miximo models and i'll show you how to
load them
first we find one we like and there's a
lot of cool choices like look at this
dude
probably make a pretty sweet zombie game
or something anyway browse around
ultimately i settled on this little guy
here with the shoe sticking out of his
head
you need to download him i download the
fbx in
t-pose first and all that means is he's
just standing there with his
arms straight out then we go and find
some suitable animations
again so many to choose from let's just
pick something basic for now
hit download and i choose without skin
since we downloaded the model separately
already
now that we have the model let's look at
the code first thing we need is to
import the fbx loader
which this line does then i added this
load animated model function
and inside that we defined an instance
of an fbx loader
this line here loads the model and this
is where we need to go and add a little
bit more logic
after the model loads we want to load
another fbx for the animation which is
what this line does here
now inside here we create an animation
mixer with the original zombie model and
then call clip action to create an
animation action for the animation
now to actually animate it's as simple
as calling
dot play and that's it there we go he's
animated
and just to cap this off we'll throw
together this little controller here and
make this guy
move around i'll make this little
character controls class and there's a
little bit of logic here where we listen
for key up and key down
events as you can see we just move
forward and backward and turn left and
right
based on that then down here in the
update code is where we apply movement
to the zombie model and we go and load
this up
hurray is walking around now this is
just the start you can load up
many more animations blend them together
make them stand
walk run attack die whatever
hope you all enjoyed this remember to
like and subscribe i'll make a much more
advanced
character controller in a future
tutorial but this should get you all
started
like always code is available on github
probably
if i remember to upload it if not just
remind me and i'll see you next time
cheers